okay hello everyone uh welcome to a
design review about chemistry
and we're actually reviewing something
this will is not for version 13 it's for
something after version 13.
um i believe this might be our first
design review of something fundamentally
for
post
version 13 that we've been working on
for a while
all right this is about molecular
fingerprints
so it's basically uh an encoder for
molecules
and
why is this different from
the net encoder technology this is a
feature feature detector story isn't it
right so it does i mean it is in a sense
uh like featurizing a molecule but it's
um
and uh we did meet after the last time
we we uh discussed this uh with the
machine learning group and it is kind of
uh
in a in a some form hooked up to feature
extraction there's a few named
um extractors there
okay so why isn't it just a feature
extractor
right because um so in general like the
people who are interested in
fingerprints um are gonna want to be
able to tweak a lot more parameters than
are normally
um available for a in a feature
extractor
so is that true i mean don't feature
extractors also have tweakable
parameters
i don't know the extent to which
those uh
not in
let's see not in any way uh not to the
extent that these do i don't know if
there are sub options for these uh
do we have anybody from the machine
learning group who could speak to that
no
um
so i did uh
not with us today so
when i met with with them they were of
the opinion that that i mean uh can we
find somebody can somebody find somebody
does anybody available uh
yeah do you want me to just ask shoddy
for somebody yes okay to suggest
somebody okay go ahead
right um it's that uh so with these
feature extractors these named feature
extractors they they wanted something
that was really kind of turn key that
was uh um would do
what the user will expect it to and will
just kind of fit in there and and work
and in general from what i've read and
looking at the i mean just as a observer
machine learning and chemistry is
not um
it's not nearly as mature as it is for
video or audio or images i know but it's
going the exact same direction
right but it's so at the moment when uh
various people do uh do machine learning
um they write papers about it they
basically have to at each time
write their own encoder because it
the different features that get encoded
into
the the bit vector are different for
each um each purpose you need i
understand i understand so there's not
just one feature detector i mean just
like that's why i mean in
in the case of machine learning we learn
a feature detector these are named ones
but we can also learn one
okay so let's just take a look at um
so you have
if i look at one of these
this is just numeric array
right
it's just uh and if you normaled it it
would be uh ones and zeros
okay
okay and
so uh and we had previously looked at
the uh the bit vector data structure as
a return type but uh um
it just doesn't the they're not as built
into the system as as a the numeric
array and so i mean what's nice is with
that numeric array you can feed it in
the most distance functions most other
functions throughout the kernel and
they'll understand what to do with it
okay you know what
this is not a properly integrated design
i mean this is something where
okay let's let's look at a few more of
these things
i see so you can make a distance matrix
between molecules from this yes
right if you supply it with a
dissimilarity
no obviously this is not going to make
it this is a string option for a
right so i mean
so i really want to get your opinion on
which way to go with these before i uh
code them what is molecule the
similarities that
is that something that's going to be
added to our collection of dissimilarity
functions
yes i think i
i believe so uh
wait i mean that's the plan and by the
way
what's the status of our graph encoders
for neural nets
do you understand the question i mean
we're doing
right which are clearly closely related
to
encoders for i notice someone on our
live stream is making the same comment
that
look
um
you know it's it's a and i don't know
whether those again have many parameters
i think that they do
so i think we may have already solved
the problem of representing a feature
extractor with parameters
um
ethan is saying the graph encoders suck
our graph encoders or graph encoders in
general um
so if we've solved how to to make a
feature extractor and with usable like
documented parameters that you pass in
that wasn't expressed to me when i when
i met with okay what so you got the
wrong if i might say so we have the
wrong people in this meeting because we
clearly need you know you're asking me
a bunch of details about how feature
extraction works i thought there was a
separate documentation page
there isn't so i'm a little bit
surprised by that i thought there was a
separate documentation page for each of
these feature extractor types
okay
and one of them i would expect to be you
know your different kinds of
uh molecular fingerprints
because i mean again here if i take one
of these
um
notice that
this gives a feature extraction function
i think you can get the the um the
actual vectors out
um
uh
okay i you know what we we need whoever
is working on the graph encoders and so
on because they're clearly going to be
deeply related to this
and what what what roughly is the
algorithmic approach taken by these
molecular fingerprint things they're
presumably doing some kind of graph
encoding is that true
right so they so
you find some type of substructure
within the molecule be it a pair of
atoms or a group of atoms and then you
take those atoms plus the information
about them
and you hash that
to some integer
and then um
either you keep track of that integer
and how many times that substructure
shows up or you
fold that integer down to a number
between 0 and 2048 and you set that bit
to 1.
what
so what number sorry what so let's see
so you take it you take it you look
through the molecule and you find all
the different substructures you take
that substructure and you hash it to a
64-bit integer
that's random
okay
and then if you want if you want to
represent that as a finite bit vector
you then take that 64-bit integer and
they call it folding it down but i mean
essentially hash is flat
is it flattened it's just flattened
so it's just you get a list of those
things and you flatten the list is that
right
well
no no uh for each individual
substructure it it's a it's originally
hashed to as jason said an integer
that is a very large space that those
all of those different
integers and in chemistry they have
frequently folded them down into uh
0 to 247
uh and then call that a bit vector
that they would then use in a
dissimilarity measure
that's that's the history okay so
basically what happened what you're
saying is if you just took
your molecule and you took its smile
string and you hashed it you would have
something which has no chemical
you know no reason to make nearby
molecules be nearby okay so what you're
doing is you're saying take the graph
look at its graph substructure
and take each lump of substructure and
do a random hash on that lump of
substructure on the grounds that if two
molecules are the same they have lumps
of substructure that are identical as in
they'll have the same hash
basically that's it and and it's the
degree of overlap of those hashes
between the two molecules that's the
similarity or the distance well no but
but each each substructure each hash
is just completely random in hash space
so the whole point is what you're saying
is the molecule can be decomposed into
subgraphs
each one of those subgraphs is subgraph
number 312 or something right and it has
no relation to subgraph 311 but that's
what you've got is basically a
you're you're saying
which are the subgraphs that occur
in this molecule it's one way to do it
would be to say
you know if you can do it in a more
human level you would say this molecule
has a i see i'm trying to learn
chemistry aromatic ring or something
this molecule has a such and such
you know a phenyl group or something i
don't know what i'm talking about but
you know
these named sub-pieces of molecules
functioning right
there
so they're good
functional groups so you're trying to
match functional groups between
different sets of molecules
and basically as a skeleton as well but
yes
whether or not they have you know two
similar things that we might think of
similarly when we look at it in a graph
theoretical sense whether or not they
hash to nearby integers is your that's
been irrelevant for chemists yeah
hopeless right well well actually no the
you know it it's it's a label of
something that's in the molecule and if
two molecules both have that same label
they both have that sub part
and they're similar in that respect
and it's the aggregate of all those
similarities that gives the overall
molecular similarity i get it i get it i
mean if you have two things
that are have the same functional groups
but they're arranged in a different way
you would have similar hashes but the
molecules would be different molecules
is that a true statement yes because
other things would be different uh
between them as well besides those two
specific subgroups yeah but in in the
construction of your
uh fingerprint for the molecule how does
the other graph structure independent of
the subgraphs how does that
affect the fingerprint
it will contribute other uh
substructures to it so the substructures
they overlap right like i see i see i
see i see i see so you're decomposing it
and the point is that
okay i get it
so if if i was doing that for a vector
of integers for example what you'd be
saying is i mean it would be as simple
as taking
some random vector of integers for
example
um
the analog of what you're talking about
is let's say i say random integer
um
i don't know
and then what i would say is just
partition that comma
and then i would hash each of those
subgroups is that right
optimal subspaces
what do you mean by subspaces this is
i mean i i just you you enforced an
order well
oh i see subsets you're saying arbitrary
subsets okay not necessarily though
space sub spaces so but the way i mean
the way that you partition that you you
connect you only group the things that
are near each other so you're getting
like linear substructures in that linear
list right
yeah
okay okay fine but all right so then
and so there are different uh
different algorithms for how to generate
those substructures do you look at pairs
do you look at
paths
do you uh use a circular radius to to
define a subject
yeah i get it i can see how that would
work
okay
and so
let's see i understand that like all the
different um parameters in that is
not
perfectly well uh integrated with the uh
the rest of the system and so that's why
i put forth the idea that the
fingerprints could go in the wfr if
well i don't know i i don't think that
should be necessary i think that they
can be okay this thing here
is doing a search
when you say cns agents that's
so okay so this is a known list and this
is really doing the same thing that
nearest does is that correct yes
okay and why isn't this just a distance
function
let's see so
so with when doing molecule similarity
you need both uh how to um uh to what
different types to make and then how to
compare them so that's like a feature
okay so this is so presumably when we
make a feature space part of molecules
we would be using
if i'm not mistaken
these
fingerprint feature feature vectors yes
to make the feature space plot and then
dimension reducing them
yes and so essentially what i want right
now you can say feature extractor goes
to and then give a string or a different
string and i'd like there to be the
possibility of a molecule fingerprint
function
which you've specified all the different
parameters although we could also
imagine something and this is why we
need somebody from the machine learning
group
something where you give the name of
feature extractor or you have some
wrapper that represents these feature
extractors together with a whole giant
association of attributes
used by by the future extractor
stephen i don't think the odds are good
of getting someone from the machine
learning group okay well i don't think
this then i don't think the odds are
good of resolving this meeting okay
okay but i mean just to understand this
better
um
i think what you're saying seems
fine i mean except that i just don't
think
i think this is exactly a feature
extraction function and i think it
should be treated the same way why is
this any different i mean this is uh
it's exactly the same type of thing
right what what's the difference between
this
and
feature extraction
function i don't know anything about the
latter okay well it's fine but that's
that's
that's you know
that's what having an integrated design
is about is that i'm telling you it's
the same thing right and that's what you
should be using
and maybe this will push to get more
detail and more documentation of how
these feature extractors work
um
and uh
ethan on our live stream has been
talking about how bad our graph feature
extractors are so it sounds like there's
a there's a feature extractor gap here
and um
i wasn't aware that we had implemented
that
yeah well okay so there's been a lack of
communication here so let's solve that
okay
um okay is that other stuff that needs
to be so
you've got
a bunch of different parameters
effectively for your feature extractors
here like the substructure keys
you know molecule substructure keys is
probably the name of that feature
extractor and then it has various kinds
of of um
uh
of parameters associated with it yes
yes although i mean so in that
particular case you are supplying a
literal list of molecule patterns and
then it is uh
checking for them
so that's so that uh substructure
where's the list of patterns so here
entity value uh element atomic symbols
so basically it was so in this case it's
just checking it's essentially getting
the molecular formula it's it's a really
it's a toy example so so this is
by substructure patterns you mean that
is the function applied to substructures
oh no that is the function that is
determining what the quote substructure
of the given molecule is
right
so you could put in your your own
patterns there uh
but what's it going to be applied to i
mean that particular it's applied to the
whole molecule object or what
right so you do so it essential so you
would put a list of molecule patterns in
that where you ever highlighted and then
the fingerprint would have zero or one
depending on whether the molecule had
that substructure okay fine
fine
i mean so what you're saying is okay so
there's a language so you're basically
saying these fingerprints work by
identifying substructures
and
then your output type there is count
vector okay
so
you're saying you break the molecule
down into these substructures each
substructure has a code hash code or
otherwise assigned to it
then you have a combiner function that
takes those individual codes
and packages them together into the
final output is that right
very yes that's very succinct that's a
good summary
okay all right so then
what
okay so these are the ways that you are
selecting
which substructures you're going to pick
up from the graph is that right
okay
so i mean i just don't think this is
terribly complicated i think that this
is this seems like it fits well into the
rubric of feature extractors
but the feature of tractors are going to
need some extra parameters hopefully you
are going to have a bunch of named
molecular fingerprints which are what
people typically want
um
yeah um i do have one one question
though about the features that that
ultimately get extracted
generally the chemists have dealt with
vectors of of zeros and ones or counts
um and the machine learning features
tend to end up as arrays that can go
into some kind of neural net generally
um
so is there a way we can handle both
sorry say that again could you just
repeat for a second okay uh
traditionally in chemistry
the features
end up becoming a list of of bits zeros
and ones presence absence
or a a vector of frequencies or counts
how many times each one occurs
and in the feature strat extractors for
machine learning that we have
they ultimately end up as an array so it
can go into a neural net
and we don't want to necessarily
if you know uh shoehorn
what has traditionally been
yeah these are just vectors too that's
what neural nets eat
right but sometimes we want to return
this association with couch which is
association like um so if you go down to
um
uh one little bit there so the we made
that um
when we made the finger printer of the
substructure keys
what its output is is like that h goes
to six c goes to six so it tells you
these substr not only okay not only did
it set bits but it also um has an
explainable version of what the feature
extractor is okay well that's exactly
what people want to do in machine
learning as well they want explainable
feature vectors
so i don't know what we're doing exactly
for explainable feature vectors but this
is probably the same kind of thing that
is in in that particular case what one's
often doing is saying you know which
features were the more important in
determining this result
and uh that's a little different from
what you have here but it's the same
structural problem i think
um
uh
right um
so
yeah well look i think the main point
here is
let's get
um
um
you know
[Music]
um what am i trying to say let's should
i meet with with etienne yes him walnut
and then
julio
okay
jason please include me in that
conversation as well i have a lot of
experience with these things
the
all right and then you know
my bottom line is it's possible that
there should be a separate molecular
fingerprint function but it's also got
to interoperate with all the machine
learning stuff because then it plugs
into feature space plot and all these
kinds of things dimension reduce all
these types of things that we would
expect to work
um the question of whether of how the
human readable i mean that's the only
thing that i understand as i understand
it that you want
that is not obviously available in
feature extraction is a human readable
version of what the feature vector is
is that correct
yes
well i mean so to a degree i mean i also
really like the it let's see to a
chemist they don't norm
the people who are interested in these
might not think feature extractor when
they when they want to get some molecule
fingerprints like having the name
the molecule fingerprint would have a
certain
well we can consider that but let's make
sure that we understand
that i mean i don't know
we have a few other special case
uh feature encoders i think i think
there are ones with color which are i
mean like we have a color nearest and so
on
um
that isn't just i think we do at least
that isn't just the generic nearest
maybe we don't i think we do
because i think it has um
no we don't
maybe it's just positive distance
oh okay that's what i'm thinking of
right because that's a special distance
and a molecular distance
is again something
i mean presumably we need um um didn't
we already have such a thing molecular
distance molecular dissimilarity is that
not already a function
it is not um i mean i so i proposed this
a while ago and i have uh a let's say a
fingerprint similarity function in the
in the repository okay fine okay maybe
that's where i'm thinking of it from
look i think it's really built in
whether there is a molecule fingerprint
function name let's find out how well
this maps into the feature extraction
world
and take it from there is there anything
else we need to cover right now right
here
now that's it
can you just for my
um
a little bit of the road map of um some
of the other things that we'll be seeing
in chemistry
uh in the near future
what's ever happened to like electronic
structure computations and so on
let's see uh what's the next thing you
want to do is the chemical reactions the
reaction templates right
right so we have we have a reaction a
template reaction that is like a an
operator that can uh affect
transformation and so it
basically transforms graph patterns from
one side to the other
um okay so it's that particular one i'm
going to say right now
you know we obviously have done tons of
stuff on graph rewriting the physics
project that has not yet been
imported into the graph framework it's
going to be
let's make sure that we have something
which is compatible between these
chemistry graphs
graph theory graphs
and the stuff that has been coming in
from the physics project and so on
because i think your your chemical
reaction
uh
you know by the way i think these graphs
are going to be closely related to these
uh two-way pattern things that are also
relevant for theorem proving etc i think
it's all the same type of thing and we
would like to have a nice coherent
design for all of that stuff
but you should design what you need for
the chemistry thing but expect that
i mean it's you're going to specify
molecules with pattern variables i
assume
that's what you already have right
they're random r's that are pattern
variables in molecules correct
yep yep
smart season smart yes
right and then what's going to happen is
you're going to say this graph with this
form has this
you know
wild card blank thing in some place
now you can
you know put anything in there and
that's what represents the reaction is
that correct
more or less yeah so you i mean you
define uh um
patterns on the left and like identify
where what happens to them on the right
side
conditions yeah it's it is the graph
rewriting
and you know we
what's not specified
in the pattern for the reaction is that
uh blank for all the rest of the graph
for all the rest of the molecule
and sometimes we do specify that
explicitly in the reaction pattern
well
the graph rewriting yes okay hold on so
an expression rewriting slash dot
as opposed replace takes the whole
expression and does what it does with it
replace all
you know recurses in the expression and
can take a subpart of the expression and
transform that yes
so you're saying the default for
molecules is the second case is that
right
yes
because
basically that's what happens in the
flask
replace only actually the best analogy
for this because if you have two
identical functional groups at different
parts of the molecule they're still
supposed to react the same to a given
reagent so yeah slash that is a good
analogy for this
but
so if you have
two functional groups like at different
ends of a molecule and you have one a
reaction that transforms one a function
a functional group
to a different form
then you could have two different
products when you when you apply that
reaction yes it could go to the left to
go to the right and it could also be
more like both of those
yeah
if you apply it twice
it would replace this is in the category
of everything
you know all simple things are invented
many times i mean the you know this is
exactly these multi-way graphs
that that's why
um
and uh in fact there's a group we've
been interacting with in france that
have built a bunch of things that are
based on category theory ideas and so on
that are chemical reaction networks
and trying to understand the
correspondence of those to graph
rewriting that we've done for physics
project and so on but i mean if i look
at that sometime in the past one of you
got me to buy this book about name
reactions and it just has this catalog
and i have another book some ej corey
book about about logic of chemical
synthesis which is
basically
you know it's a great big list of
reactions
and so
you know looking through there my
assumption is that each of those
reactions are going to turn into a graph
pattern
essentially yeah that that's that's my
view of the world as well
okay
and then
then what's going to happen is
those
in terms of our chemical reaction
functions
there will be some essentially multi-way
graph that says
these are the different possible things
that could happen given this
transformation rule to this particular
molecule
and presumably each one will have a
weighting that's determined by all kinds
of thermodynamic features and so on
that are fast that's that's a
possibility yes
or in practical practical terms some you
may get a higher yield of one particular
product than
the other
yeah depending on reaction conditions
conditions
yeah it could be thermodynamically
controlled or kinetically controlled
vertically controlled yeah
but by kinetically controlled do you
mean the molecule is a certain shape and
you can't get the thing into it you
can't sort of
kinetically move the the one molecule to
fit with the other molecule or what uh
kinetically controlled i think is more
having to do with how many
uh
things you've got reacting where it's
thermodynamically controlled it will go
to the lowest energy one right it's a
dynamic equilibrium and even though
you know a is formed first it could
rearrange to the other product b
eventually
okay depending on the reaction
well you guys know that i'm you know i'm
trying to understand some of the stuff
about foundations of chemistry for my
uh
strange
purposes of trying to apply
physics project
ideas and particularly of relevance i
think is this kind of microstructure of
reactions that is not just asking what
is the total amount of this product
that's produced but asking what's the
detailed causal graph of which molecules
interact with your eternal molecules
it's kind of the below thermodynamics
version of what's happening i don't know
whether that resonates with anything i
mean it when you think about
what you're describing in terms of one
functional group doing this and then the
thing rearranges and so on that's
one level of description is everything
works according to thermodynamics but
another level of description is
individual molecules have individual
transformations that happen on them and
it's only in the aggregate you get
thermodynamic behavior
yeah i think so sure sure
yeah you can see that
so actually okay this is my chemistry
moment and then we have to wrap up here
my chemistry moment is i was trying to
understand
these things like auto-catalytic sets
do you guys understand those
i'm
not familiar with them by that term you
know well so i know that term
okay they're studied particularly by
people who are interested in origin of
life kinds of things and they're
basically
uh
sort of
molecular cycles
that
have some kind of self-amplification
property
it's it's but this whole question about
looking at the detailed kind of causal
graph
or the detailed sort of evolution graph
of what molecule gives what molecule et
cetera et cetera et cetera
how would that be
i mean in traditional sort of
chemistry one is mostly concerned with
what will ultimately turn into odes that
represent the concentration of different
chemicals correct
well that's one thing uh some people
interested in that others are just
interested in being able to make a
particular
chemical compound
right in good yield
yeah right to find a particular path
through this multi-way graph that gives
that particular result yes yes and
others are interested in stability of
molecules and and their structure and
then um
yeah
yeah or the kinetics of the formation
this is sorry this is com irrelevant but
sandra on a livestream is asking about
that distance function and i have no
idea why that's still experimental
it's a different group but somebody
should take that and ask that question i
have no idea why that why that hasn't
been promoted to the system context okay
we'll pass it along
uh all right i should probably um
disappear here but but uh
um
all right this was our the beginning of
a new development cycle
and um
uh i think
this yeah we
we talked through this and connect with
the machine learning group and oh there
are various comments on the live stream
saying we should get
uh
we should get a version of alpha fold
in um or something like it in the neural
net repository yes i i agree
um and it'll be nice to get although
it'll be nice to get a version
one of the faster versions of that
um so that it's actually something
that's realistic for people to do
in um
uh
something more like real time at least
to an approximation
all right but i think i have to run off
here
so thanks a lot guys thanks to folks on
the live stream and
see you later